[Music]
in doing what he loved news submitted by
util of doodles a static comedian died
on stage during a live promit izing and
they thought it was part of the no it's
someone's to have a fun to snipe them
offstage or what yeah there's a British
guy right uh-huh
a British comedian named incognito my
station yeah that's a stage name like
incognito yeah this isn't a video of him
dying is it
no he's another photo it's like V for
Vendetta yes he's been doing comedy for
decades that's awesome and so what's
awesome but he's been doing it for
decades yeah gunshot I was just a door
opening I'm just always ready
we're not that see people like a load
and rice into their car she's not wrong
about that yeah so they're saying that
during his performance right right
before he passed that he actually joked
about dying on stage so that makes sense
why people would lie he ended up like
leaning leaning back in his chair you
put his head back and his arms back and
his shoulders were twitching so people
thought that it was fall dude that's why
they were laughing for five minutes
before the real have to be in a
simulation cuz you can't plan a better
death as a comedian okay like I died as
my punchline
yeah he was acting it out yeah and then
it actually happened during that zone
and this is the most famous he probably
ever was I like your honesty I think he
was Britain but of all the ways to go
out I think he would have wanted it that
way
what are you guys what about the talk of
the base he would didn't he die at the
dock didn't he die I don't remember the
dock could the big guy yeah yeah oh wait
was it a plane crash in a crash song is
about him dying no no no no no no but
he's saying that something I think there
was a plane crash in it and it landed in
the bay so they please say he died
that's how you died yeah you all know I
don't know we're not we're [ __ ]
tragedy eating show we're new so it's
like 50/50 we get it right
yeah 37 new chefs all the same you
believe it we're a commentary show but
you know what we're more realer than
fake news JK commentary people acted
like the mainstream media is [ __ ]
always right anyway they get a lot of
[ __ ] they [ __ ] up so much Jim they do
so what did he die it was a hard time or
slow there see like they haven't
concluded it yet but they're just saying
that it seemed like it was something oh
who did he have survived had they called
have a someone called the cut always
hear those stories or like oh you're
just two minutes with a [ __ ] died yet
and then this is one of the cases well
it's too sad what kind of chair I just
have a lot of semantic questions like
what kind of chair can you see you're in
and not fall off of like standing
comedians have like a stool true yeah if
you fall back on a stool they you're
kind of like if your majority of your
body weights here then like maybe it
just looked like a really dope act out
yeah sometimes I'm afraid of having a
stroke cuz I guess so [ __ ] mad like
earlier though when he was talking about
dying in front of them he did he was
talking about having a heart attack or a
stroke in front of them I knew it in
that himself
yeah whoa see that's what I'm saying
wait it was a suicide mmm are so key to
the drug oh and he went out with the
bang detective of the year he probably
had stage four cancer he knew he's gonna
die he was like here's how I'm going out
and pray he pranked the whole world
lawyer Lauren on the show yeah yeah so
they're saying that there was a an
audience member that was a paramedic so
he did perform CPR and then the rest of
the audience were removed once they
figure it out cuz they they were there
he wasn't like five minutes imagine how
all the audience people feel that
they're like I can't believe I was
laughing yeah
he was dying yeah I would take this away
be like oh my god you know what happened
yes I think that'd be I'd be like this
is [ __ ] awesome he died doing what he
loved
yeah he's a comedian dying doing his set
and people were cracking up yes like if
a stripper slips and falls and cracks
her head like down the pole oh that's
work she dad it worked I'd like to
believe that strippers are passionate
about their work but you made it real
they're probably drugged out and they
have to do it how would you attack a
news oh really yeah only what you love
you're gonna traumatize teeth so she's
dead what if she can't repeat guys
because he sees me dead he's like oh my
god I bet he has a heart attack but yeah
I like that she's like if I don't live
you don't live either [ __ ]
you're not getting remixed said that he
does I want that he doesn't want to live
longer if I died he would say some [ __ ]
like I wanna live all of you you know
statistically though for the wife dies
like come in a year know why they [ __ ]
better the husband dies the wife still
is along tonight yeah you know why yeah
we get hotter more attractive we start
going to the gym yeah the wrinkles go
away our kids go up again oh you know
why why he stresses the [ __ ] out job
social network support women have social
support
it's because the wives take care of the
husbands they cook them dinner they know
the finances they do all the stuff and
so when the wife dies the guy doesn't
know how to take care of himself
I think I'm [ __ ] oh [ __ ] my husband REE
he does the finance I'm gonna book it
start to death okay well you come away
with me goddamn it
oh sure oh yeah there's there's a social
network I see social network but then
you I did I would have extended the
dying over here and you're like I don't
know you wanna know you I'm sorry
you know like stay a little bit longer
know about your husband's bidet
breathing okay you could come with me in
ballyglenn there you go you see you're
not alone all right it was a technique I
shared with everyone not just in
previous video fine everyone can benefit
from it yeah butthole breathing the view
of the day you know you can drink
alcohol through your bottle and you get
drunker faster if you drink alcohol
through your eyeballs - can you suck it
on to that yeah you'll go blind I don't
get the but like you stick a straw in
there and then ya straight it just into
your blood you could get all the way the
news faster and you could die faster
because your livers not processing milk
okay that's like edibles you know are
you gonna do that in Vegas pour some
liquor up your ass shot shot shots and
everyone starts [ __ ] pulling down
their pads like that that's that
breathing out of his butt chuggin you
put like a beer bong in your bag I think
that's a white person thing go I'm sorry
I tell you the white person being about
vodka-soaked tampons no Mexican people
don't do that [ __ ] you put that it's
soft it's all expanded yeah you know
what I mean I guess it becomes a
butterfly no what if it's still in the
we're stupid example you don't know that
I'm too scared about talking Jacques
thing I've seen too many videos with
girls that lost their legs and stuff
they're like I wore tampons all my life
didn't one time it took my leg away and
I'm like oh my god where they bought
this tampons
maybe they just need to take a shower no
they like did at the same amount of time
each time and like just one out of
nowhere knows maybe they didn't take
care of where they placed their time the
tampons and then like the tampon got
some bacteria they put it inside knowing
your luck you might catch it exactly
that's what I'm saying I'm doing
that's disgusting we need toxic shot
that means you have an infected [ __ ] I
don't know what it means it could be a
reaction to
chemical inside of the tampon that's
like [ __ ] yeah like a dope on our tits
that's what Britney Spears toxic was all
about the tap was too high she can't
calm down
so it's stuck in there you figured it
out yeah what is this thing about this
is why we all I think cope with comedy
is because [ __ ] like this is so so
[ __ ] up that you got a laugh about it
yeah
you would have laughed about it at all
baby laughing right yeah he's like up
there like haha so that's a great way to
go you know the funniest thing sometimes
it's the most tragic you give it some
time ironically I have a few things that
happen in my life that I'm still not
laughing it yeah I think it's only funny
force ironic yeah like that's pretty
ironic yeah I mean there's nothing
ironic about your mom beating your ass
but there's something very funny about
it hmm
I got jumped in college and I think it's
funny right yeah cuz I the cop had to
hold my hair back while at puked that's
pretty funny
that is pretty funny being taken care of
by a cop yeah did you get done I got job
cuz I was wearing a skirt that was too
short
they beat your ass because you're being
too sad Oh
some guy I was wasted walking to go be
my friends in my college town and some
guy tackled me I was on the phone this
is how I was so drunk I was on the phone
with my roommate
this guy tackles me I go I gotta call
you back and I hung up and like scream
my ass off and he ran off and then the
comp heard me from the street screaming
so loud because most people most like
rape people oh yeah right no he didn't
either
I was written painting us what the [ __ ]
okay no cuz I wanted to rape them as in
like you got beat up
oh he tackled me and that was he was
trying to rape you probably yeah guys
yeah oh well he tackled me that hurt I
had a bruise in my butt damn that's
Kayla want you to put up a fight they
just want someone who's like gonna be
quiet and so I started screaming you ran
away and the cops were like what's her
name and I was like I don't want to
incur it myself because I'm underage and
they they took me to the station to give
a damn you smart while you were drunk a
statement drunk yeah to give a statement
and they made the other cop sit in the
back cuz I didn't want to feel like I've
been arrested and then on the way home
they had to pull over let me puke can
you hold my hair back oh my gosh I feel
you though like it's it does it at the
stories initial shock but then you think
about it and you're like that is kind of
funny cuz then I imagined this guy being
a punk-ass [ __ ] and then he's like oh
my god I can't rape her worse because I
used to make a joke because my mom gave
me this email where it was like how not
to get raped and it one of the first
things was like to say stop don't rape
I'm so [ __ ] funny but it was the
reasoning being was because you know
they don't want to make a scene yes they
want someone that's not gonna make a
scene so if you like say stop it really
read it out you know one of the main
things that rape is try to do is they
try to take you immediately to an area
that is like hidden so stay in it I was
in a back alley walking through to get
to the front Oh drew this way I always
go but it was late at night I was drunk
and there's like a list of things that
rapists look forward to and I checked
all the boxes like being on your phone
is a distraction they actually looking
for that most people think if I'm on my
phone no one will drop me but you're
distracted I had my hair in a ponytail
there like things I can hold on to I
bring a dress I was wasted but I had on
tights and you can't get I don't have
you ever tried to take tights off a girl
mm-hmm no so I could barely get them off
myself game but sometimes I like a lemon
Callie that's like a cartoon way to get
raped I know
that's like but it was like in college
so it wasn't like an LA alley it was
like a safe alley that I've walked
through a thousand times but you don't
know because Jeffrey Dahmer would go to
college towns and do this to Jeffrey
Dahmer was he's a whole nother level
well you survived which is very good and
funny yeah what a minute laughs later me
to go with you oh my laughs later yeah
there once you tackled it looks funny
your hair probably went out like that
hold my hair back wage you know what
that's that's how you're coping with
that trauma and you're more powerful for
that and sitting of letting that
incident you teach you in making you a
victim because when I'm a billionaire
y'all could help me be the debate and
pretend and be in dark alleys and me up
you have the legs for it no I do I do
you might you know you know what I'm it
right but we got to work together on
this you got to work together all this
okay
[Music]